[Music]
all right CNN once again taking heat for
mocking Trump supporters take a look at
this he also knows deep in his heart
that Donald Trump couldn't find Ukraine
in a map if you had the letter U and a
picture of an actual physical crane
that's next to it he knows that this is
you know an administration defined by
ignorance of the world and so that's
partly him playing to their base and
playing to their audience you know the
the the credulous Boomer Rube demo that
backs Donald Trump that wants to think
that the dog Trump's a smart one in
there Oh y'all know y'all elitist sir
you would lead us with your geography in
your maps and your spelling given the my
path it's good right yeah that was a
good one I needed that no look at you
with your cosmopolitan bias the liberal
network getting intense backlash and the
president is fighting back saying quote
Don Lemon the dumbest man on television
with terrible ratings end quote
Ivanka Trump calling the clip disgusting
so Greg does this is this one of those
moments where the media left show their
bias against a large chunk of the
country well first I want to tell you I
did come up with a drink called the
lemon Rickey it's half pompous half ass
I'm all for ridicule you ridicule the
guy though and what would the problem
with CNN is they ridicule everybody and
this has always been kind of their thing
it's like they really do look down their
noses at most at at least half of
America it's no wonder the ratings are
in a tank if that is a pure campaign ad
somebody's got to make it but I will say
this Rick Wilson there is definitely
something wrong with him I don't know
what it is but there's something wrong
with him the joke wasn't that bad
it was lemons just overdoing it hyper
dramatic oh my god this is the best
thing ever like he was having an organic
Jimmy Fallon on SNL yeah yes no no don't
ever soil foul and by just comparing him
to Don Lemon but it killed me the
overreaction was just so silly and sad
and CNN's in trouble and they need
no wonder they're watching us all the
time they have their media crew watching
Fox to figure out what we're doing right
that's on you yes well maybe it's
respecting people's people's votes and
people's points of view even when they
don't score with your own and I think
that that's one of the biggest problems
what do you see here
well many people are the first to try to
point out and you know put like Rick
Wilson and others when the president
says something impolite or harsh about
another person they will immediately and
I don't like it either I've said it from
the beginning I'd only like although I'm
like nickname I really liked it was a
little Rocket Man that was my favorite
wine but other than I think ones that
are personal in nature I don't like and
then I also knew that as soon as Hillary
Clinton said deplorable
like that was it here we go and and also
I don't understand I am I guess using a
southern accent to mimic somebody who
apparently is dumb and doesn't read is
really offensive people come from
different regions of the country you
have actions from people from all over
the world it has nothing to do with your
intelligence it has to do with where you
were raised
and so that that it I think is is
offensive yeah how many surgeons have
southern accents I mean I'm pretty sure
a million and that's why I don't make
sweeping generalizations about groups of
people that offended by and I'm not
offended on behalf of someone by that
but you know I'm usually the one that
offends other people so stay out of my
lane now I'm gonna go but so I have a
unique understanding of the situation
the two guys on the right in the left
there like hired guns they're not gonna
pay a price that's true there's no
parent company there Don Lemon is the
guy in trouble because he's supposed to
be the straight news guy and CNN is
already in trouble with bad ratings and
he's got problems on the side so I'm
sure sucker calls him into the office
and says guy you're you're a primetime
person and you're and you're you're
losing it because someone is making fun
of millions of Americans
so there's having with him I think he's
going dawn that was brilliant your
comedic instincts were spot-on this is
what we're supposed to be doing
that's what's happening over there at
CNN and they deserve the ridicule
because like you said they're gonna turn
around an ad like this or just give a
talking point to every Republican to
Donald Trump to hammer the left a hammer
the media in an election year where
Democrats have to regain their footing
with white working-class Americans you
know non-college educated people in Iowa
Florida and the Rust Belt so not great
time but there are plenty of people in
the South who have advanced degrees who
look at someone like Bernie Sanders and
say he does not represent my interest I
like my money I want to take care of my
children I will not vote for him
therefore I will vote for Donald Trump
not everyone with the southern accent
he's a deplorable rube won I would agree
there's no argument there
I was surprised though to hear that Greg
and Jesse both said they wouldn't take
any great offense at this that they
think that if you want to have this kind
of ridicule I think the word you used I
think no I said that ridicule is great
when it's directed at a person but not
at a group they directed it it because
people because I think that nobody is no
secret CNN is more liberal right MSNBC
is a liberal network right and Don Lemon
I disagree with you on this I don't
think that he's a straight news guy I
think he's a host own opinion hosts and
people no no no he's on camera saying
he's a straight news but he doesn't do a
pick I disagree because he does opinion
monologue he just got so I agree he's
very straight news the shots piercings
shots on Fox News New Year's now what oh
you get away with anything we go back
it's our but Rick Wilson's a Republican
for his old career that's how he became
record no he found his identity because
Trump he doesn't like Trump but he's got
he's got he's got a disorder you can't
change now it's it's flooded his brain I
got that Rick Rick Rick